(offbeat uplifting music)
- [Narrator] Schools
used to look like this,
classrooms packed with students,
lunchrooms full of loud conversations,
and teachers just trying to
catch a break in the lounge.
It's a scene that now looks prime
for the spread of the coronavirus.
- You have a lot of people together
in one space for a long period of time
without masks.
We don't know if the
ventilation's any good,
and with activities like shouting,
those are all the ingredients
for a super-spreading event.
- [Narrator] That's why now,
school looks very different.
Many schools are only partially
open for in-person learning,
and others are still fully remote.
- It's not business as usual,
everything has changed.
- [Narrator] Elia Valdes has been back
in her classroom since October.
- I was very concerned
about health issues.
I knew that this was the
best thing for students,
to go in physically,
'cause that's hands-down,
they will always perform better.
- [Narrator] With the
virus still spreading,
can schools reopen safely?
What are the risks of
catching COVID there,
and how do control measures,
like wearing a mask or
increasing ventilation
change that picture?
Let's look at the classroom,
lunchroom, and break room.
- Classrooms are one place where you have
a lot of people in the room
for a long period of time,
that's pretty risky.
- [Narrator] This is particularly true
for adults or older kids.
- Age really matters in
terms of transmission,
both in terms of acquisition of COVID,
as well as transmission of SARS-CoV-2,
the virus that causes COVID.
- [Narrator] Studies have found,
that compared with adults,
children might be infected less often,
are less likely to show severe symptoms,
and are less likely to be hospitalized
for severe infection.
That said, the risk isn't
zero, even for younger kids.
We know that the virus is transmitted
in a variety of ways.
Large droplets exchanged in a close range,
small droplets lingering in the air,
and indirectly through contact
with a contaminated surface.
- If somebody who is infected with COVID
comes into a classroom
and there's no control measures in place,
then they're sitting there
breathing and talking,
and they're releasing virus into the air.
- [Narrator] Think of the
virus forming a small cloud
in front of the infected person.
Larger, virus-laden droplets
expelled from the nose or mouth,
would fall nearby, while
the smaller droplets
would float further away,
and that's just from talking normally.
- By shouting and screaming
and being emotional,
you can give these droplets superpowers,
make them smaller, which we call aerosol,
and can fly further, 10,
20 feet in some cases.
- It's gonna kinda fill
the room eventually,
especially if that room
is poorly ventilated,
and then everyone else in that room
is going to be exposed to it,
and they'll be forced to breathe it.
- [Narrator] But this
picture changes dramatically
when control measures are put in place.
Experts say the most
important one is masking.
With masks on everyone,
the infected person
would release less virus into the air.
And the others would have some protection
against the virus that remains.
- I would say the second
most important thing
is to ensure good
ventilation of the classroom.
It could be as simple as
opening some doors and windows.
- [Narrator] Doing so helps replace
the air inside the classroom,
bringing in clean air from outside.
That can remove or reduce
the virus in the room,
lowering the risk of transmission.
Physical distancing is
another way to mitigate risk.
The CDC used to recommend six feet,
but it's since changed it to three.
- There's not a magic number
for safe versus unsafe,
but the farther apart
people are, the better,
so that they're kind of out
of each other's directly exhaled breath.
- [Narrator] A study of
Massachusetts Public Schools
found that case rates
in schools maintaining
three feet of distance
were similar to those of
schools using six feet.
Prevention gets more
complicated in the lunchroom.
- So in the lunchroom
setting, it's virus heaven.
The virus is in paradise
because they have so many ways
to infect noses and mouths.
- [Narrator] That's because to eat,
students need to take off their masks,
taking away a key control measure.
To compensate, experts recommend
adding portable air cleaners
with HEPA filters, if possible.
- The portable air cleaner works
by pulling air through
it and passing it through
a really high quality filter
that filters out and
removes all the aerosols
that are in the air and all the virus
that they might contain.
And then out the other side
of the portable air cleaner
comes nice, clean, virus-free air.
- [Narrator] In the teacher break room,
cleaning the air is also really important,
because it's only adults.
- Adults, of course,
breathe more than kids do
and produce probably even per breath,
produce more aerosols.
And so let's say someone's sick,
well an adult is probably
gonna release more virus
into the air, and the
other adults in that room
are gonna be breathing more
of that air compared to kids.
- [Narrator] Surface cleaning
and hand-washing are all important here,
just maybe not as critical
as was initially thought.
- Excessive attention to surface cleaning
is taking away time and energy
from cleaning the air, which
is gonna be more important
for reducing the risk of
transmission in schools.
- [Narrator] For teachers, vaccination
is the latest control
measure, and most states
are giving K through
12 educators priority.
- I just recently got my vaccine,
so that makes me feel a lot better.
- [Narrator] Even with a vaccine,
limiting teacher interactions
with students is important.
- What can you do?
- [Narrator] Because it's still unclear
if vaccination stops transmission.
And studies have shown
adults are more likely
to transmit the virus than younger kids,
for whom vaccines aren't authorized yet.
- I would always greet
my students at the door.
Hello, how are you, come on in.
Sit down, some of them would give me hugs.
Oh, Miss Valdes, high five.
Now it's like elbow or nope,
social distance, remember,
we can't get close to one another.
- [Narrator] Experts say
the key is not relying
on any one control strategy.
Masking, distancing,
ventilation, vaccination,
and testing all have a role to play
in how schools reopen.
- So to try and keep
everything all at once,
and that laundry list in place,
it's probably going to be very
frustrating for many people.
And I think if you had to do one thing,
it's probably going to
be wearing that mask.
(uplifting music)